oggi nuovo video asr rilassante in cui
vi farò sentire un sacco di suoni
rilassanti particolare voglio farvi
vedere un nuovo time che uscito che il
boom faccio vedere la scatola che mi
riporta allora è il nuovo fishbones lime
e finora non è mai stato venduto in
italia
curiosa della apple può quindi mettetevi
comodi mettete le cuffie che potete
trovare in edicola
allora andiamo subito ad aprire la
confezione è tutto e mi piace quando che
si attenda perché mi ricorda le l'on
in pratica va scartata eccola qua
in pratica queste prime sono dei crystal
eye slide quindi prima di utilizzarli
bisogna tenerli in 10 minuti in freezer
oppure lasciarli con queen ferigo vanno
conservati al fresco perché cambiano
consistenza se vengono lasciati fuori al
taglio diventare un po più uccido xi
invece mette conservando l'incarico o in
freezer sono più più effetto cristallo
e più non si segga all'aria infatti ne
ho già aperto un paio sono super da
quando la cerniera però per adesso
nessuno della cerniera e rilassante e
poi apriamo lato allora in pratica in
ogni confezione ci sono con le palline
del facebook vuole palline per fare il
fiume slime quindi in questo caso in
questa ci sono le palline per fare il
film sarà poi apriremo altri da delle
tante quelle per fare il fish full time
e super il nostro re stella slime
ovviamente come vi ho detto prima più lo
conservate all'effetto più si stupì di
fico e pietro e caldo più diventa più
morbido sentite che suoni che fa
perché sono il rilassante
allora apriamo al 33 ball iniziata
questa viola si è capitato il rosa
quindi la pallina rosa
ecco qua trasparente adesso per creare
tacciono
[Musica]
ecco fatto l'ora di vedere come sarà la
volta di scatto avremo la prossima buon
sistema blu
[Musica]
ecco qua tutti i nostri bellissimi
ovviamente se volete potete anche
metterci quello che volete voi senza dei
clippers per farlo metallizzato e
davvero come bellissimo clear light
[Musica]
no vabbè adoro troppo questo è facebook
multicolor sono bellissime aggiungiamo
la nostra si nutre 88 le palline di roma
[Musica]
andiamo al punto che anche questo al
nostro slime smoothie che oltre al
passato e non secchiello sono chiesta
più
eccola qua il fis ball rosa lilla
[Musica]
allora abbiamo facebook
qual è invece gent rosso il palline
rosse fiscale
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ok muti grande
ora andiamo mischiarlo che tira fuori
vediamo come
enorme qua e carlo e guai avverte
mischiando un po vediamo di ricorrere di
wow persone fantastici
[Musica]
allora che colore è secondo voi sembra
un mix annunciarlo è un verde comunque
mi piace tantissimo
in più quando tornerà aprirsi ancora più
bello
allora ragazzi fatemi sapere cosa ne
pensate di questo slime a me piacciono
un sacco ma mi raccomando prima di
utilizzarli hanno tenuti in freezer
fatemi sapere se vi ha rilassato questo
iter morbido e fa un sacco di sogno però
non mi aspettavo che facesse così tanti
suoni
mi raccomando lasciata un bel live se
volete vedere altri video slime smr è
orami la squa quattro case linee su cui
potete applicare per vedere i prossimi
video e vi mando un bacione norme ti
voglio bene